all right we're going to do some street
maths here in the outdoors which i've
heard a lot about but first
my shoe is untied so we need to fix that
now most people would mess around doing
some kind of complicated knot not me i'm
a mathematician i've got masks to do
grab the two sides pass them over boom
there's your knot again in slow-mo
i've i've heard about it you know on the
math circuit people would discuss the
way that you tie your shoes right and so
i know it's been around for a long time
i know it's been passed down from
mathematician to mathematician but i'm
not familiar with the earliest uh case
and i'm i there are i have heard names
assigned to it but i've not come across
any one that particularly sticks i just
call it that brilliant way to tie your
shoes be honest with me is that how you
do your shoes i do genuinely tie my
shoes up that way there's that's i i i
know i'm always talk the talk but i i
literally tie my shoes that way uh up to
once a day once it's done looks exactly
the same right so people will go that's
an unusual knot right but if they
actually see it happening they it's like
they've seen a magic trick right people
it just that blows their minds they
can't comprehend how a knot can happen
so quickly but i'm not startled i'm a
mathematician i know what i'm doing okay
you go from completely undone stuff the
same way as a normal knot you do a
little foundation thing which oh which
mask is called a trefoil it has a
minimum of three crossings that
particular knot now to tie the actual
bow you get one shoelace that's coming
out the back you fold it forward and you
hold it on its way down so it goes up
over the loop and then down this one
curls back in the opposite direction and
again you hold it on the way down and
then all you do is you take this one on
the way down and put it under that loop
at the same time as taking this one and
putting under that loop and then you
swap them over to the other hands
and then you pull them tight
and that is your knot
and with a little bit of practice
once you tighten it hold them on the way
down cross pull knot
so the one that comes at the back you
fold it forward into a loop and then you
hold it on the way down so it goes up
and then all the way down you're
grasping it same with this one except it
goes back so starts the front curls back
hold it on the way down now you're going
to take this lace put it under that loop
at the same time taking this lace and
putting it under that loop so they go
past each other they swap hands you pull
it tight and there's your knot
people tie their shoelaces they get one
in they loop the other one around they
pull it through and which is the normal
way although i noticed of course brady
wears slip-ons
but
what's wrong with that for those of us
who have entered adulthood we do it a
long complicated way but the thing is
you end up with a knot that holds your
shoe on that's the goal here my
shoelaces
for what order people would think and
not now nothing of this is a
mathematical knot
because it has loose ends
if it has loose ends you can in
principle untie it
and you can form a different knot